there's a lot of anger in the country
over a grand jury's decision in the
briana taylor case
that has left two louisville police
officers in the hospital they were shot
last night
during the protest that is not okay
after two officers involved in taylor's
death
were not charged now the shootings
marred what had been a
largely peaceful demonstration of
outrage in a city
where a state of emergency had been
declared in advance
other protests across the country
remained peaceful
with thousands marching for change late
into the night all of this
renews the call for accountability in
how police deal with black americans our
national correspondent jericha duncan
is in louisville jericho let's start
with that shooting last night which
threatens to undermine that message what
do we do now
well you know as far as those officers
are concerned they were transported to a
local hospital with what appears to be
non-life-threatening injuries but as you
mentioned at the top of the show
this is coming at a time when you have a
city that is still grappling with the
death of brianna taylor
and the news the words from the state's
attorney general
that the officers who killed her were
justified
okay officer down right there it was a
frantic scene around 8 30 last night
after
two louisville police officers were shot
interim police chief robert schroeder
says
a suspect is in custody one is in alert
and stable the other officer is
currently undergoing surgery and stable
[Music]
although protests started peacefully
some people set trash cans on fire
around 100 people were arrested the
protests came after months of waiting
for a decision in the killing of brianna
taylor
former louisville detective brett
hankinson was indicted for his alleged
conduct
but not related to taylor's death
kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron the grand jury voted to
return
an indictment against detective
hankinson for
three counts of wanton endangerment for
wantonly placing the three individuals
in apartment three
in danger hankinson was arrested and
released on bail
the grand jury concluded that he wildly
fired 10 shots
and endangered the lives of a pregnant
woman a child
and a man who were in an apartment next
to taylors
officers jonathan mattingly and miles
cosgrove who the fbi says fired the
fatal shot
will not face state criminal charges the
use of force by mattingly
and cosgrove was justified to protect
themselves
this justification bars us from pursuing
criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death taylor was
killed on march 13th as police executed
a search warrant for drugs and money
neither were found her boyfriend kenneth
walker says he believed the police were
intruders
so he fired a single shot which hit
mattingly in the thigh
police returned fire six bullets hit
taylor
somebody kicked in the door inside my
girlfriend
walker has maintained police did not
identify themselves before they used a
battering ram
on the door cameron said the officers
did knock and announced
that information was corroborated by
another witness
law professor colin miller has worked
with taylor's family he says he believes
the grand jury did not hear all of the
evidence
and we have several witness accounts
from neighboring apartments
the neighbors saying we never heard the
police not announce
taylor's family attorney ben crump
called the decision to not charge
any officer in taylor's death outrageous
and defensive it continues to disrespect
the black women
that have permeated in american society
since they first brought us here in
1619.
the fbi is also conducting a separate
investigation looking into whether or
not police legally obtained
that search warrant and that's not all
hankinson
is also being investigated by an fbi led
task force for allegations of sexual
assault
unrelated to the briana taylor case gail
jerica thank you